GOOD EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA MY NAME IS TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH AND I SERVE AS
THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE JOIN
ME AT THE DÍAS DAY ARE VICE
CHAIR VALLADARES. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN BLOOM DR CHOI
AND MY PHONE- WE'RE ALSO JOINED.
BY OUR- CALVIN RUSH OUR CONSULT
WITH THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
POLICY UNIT. ENJOYING FROM THE
COMMITTEE OFFICES TOP OF
SEPTEMBER THE FOCUS ON. THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY FOR THIS
FAMILY ARTS COMMITTEE. TODAY'S
AGENDA HAS TWO ITEMS INCLUDING
AB EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND ACR ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THAT'S ME- AND
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ONE DOG CONSENT ACR. ONE TWENTY
FOUR BY ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. SEVEN BEFORE WE
BEGIN OUR BILL PRESENTATION I
LIKE O TAKE CARE OF SOME
LOGISTICAL HOUSEKEEPING WITH A
FEW OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY FOR THE PUBLIC
IN ROOM FOUR FOUR FOUR. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN A BILL I'LL
INVITE YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I LIKE TO ASK THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
AND YOU CAN EXIT THE HEARING
ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE YOU'RE
DONE TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. FOR DIALING WITNESSES
WILL BE ALSO USING A TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY OF.
TESTIFIED ABOUT THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THIS IN THE ARTS
COMMITTEE WEBSITE FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WEBSITE AS WELL AS YOUR
TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE BILL
PRESENTATION THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE AND WE'LL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. YOU MAY BE ASKED
BY THE MODERATOR TO IDENTIFY
WHETHER YOU'LL BE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. IF YOU'RE DIALING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL THAT ICE.
WITH MUTING YOUR LIFE CAST ON
AND YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE ASSEMBLY. ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- AS WE IMPLEMENT MATHIS TWO
CONTINUE SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. LAW ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WILL FACE
. NOW LET'S COVER THE GROUND
RULES FOR APPROPRIATE CONDUCT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS EXPANSION
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PERSONS THE
LAST FEW YEARS. CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IS PROHIBITED. SUCH
CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE TALKING OR
MAKING LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE. UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE HEARING A BILL
AND ANY OTHER DESTRUCTIVE ACTS.
TO ADDRESS ANY DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT I WILL TAKE THE
FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP. AND MORE THAN THAT
CONTINUE TO STIR UP SOME
DISRUPTIONS MAY RESULT IN
REMOVAL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED IN THE NATURE OF THE
DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT. I MAY
TEMPORARILY RECESSED THE
HEARING. IF THE CONTACT IS NOT
STOP I WILL ASSISTANCE. AND THIS
CALL. WILL FROM THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. OKAY SIR. THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY WILL NOW
TAKE A MANSON PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BOERNER HORVATH HERE HER
HAIR VALLADARES. OTHERS HERE
BLOOM. BLOOM HERE CHOI YEAH CHOI
HERE FRIEDMAN. MIKE FONG.
NAZARIAN. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
MEMBERS WILL NOW TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THERE'S ONE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
AT EACH MEMBERS DESK AND A COPY
IS ALSO COMPOSED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE PROPOSED
CONSENT ITEM S. ACR ONE SEVENTY
FOUR BY ME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THEM THE MOTION
WOULD BE- WITH A RECOMMENDATION
THAT IT BE ADOPTED. OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. MEMBERS
THERE'S BEEN IN MOTION I SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BOERNER HORVATH I. WONDER ABOUT
THE FIVE BALLADARES. UNDER AS I
BLOOM. BLOOM I CHOI CHOI HI
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MIKE FONG MY
FONG I NAZARIAN. WHAT'S ON-
WHERE SIX VOTES THAT CONSENT
ITEM ITEM CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
PASSED MOVE THE ROLE OPENS THE
MEMBERS ON TO THE VOTES. OKAY.
SEVEN TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING TO GO ON TO THE NEXT
FILE ITEM ONE WE'RE HEARING AB
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA RELATING TO THE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION WHICH WILL
BE PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIKE FONG AS A COURTESY. BEFORE
MR FONG BEGINS THIS BILL. SECOND
LET ME REMIND EVERYBODY THAT IS
THE PHONE LINES ARE NOW OPEN FOR
WITNESSES TO GET IN THE QUEUE
THE CARD NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS 877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG YOU
MAY OPEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS BEHALF
OF THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE
MEDINA TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL. ONE EIGHT ONE THREE. AT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
VESTED WITH THE SOLE DISCRETION.
TO SELECT BOXING OFFICIALS FOR
EVERY BOXING MATCH AND MOST
NOTABLY WORLD CHAMPION FIGHTS.
THIS IS TO ENSURE THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE ATHLETES. READ OUR
ECONOMIC INTERESTS ON BEHALF OF
ITS COMMISSION OR ITS LICENSEES.
THE AFOREMENTIONED ROLE OF THE
EO CAN LEAVE OPEN THE DOOR FOR A
POTENTIAL UNWANTED LITIGATION
DUE TO THE INHERENT NATURE. THAT
THE DECISIONS AT THE- MAKES OUR
DISCRETION AXE EXPONENTIALLY
MORE SO THAN THEY ARE
MINISTERIAL ACTS UNDER EXISTING
LAW A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE IS NOT
LIABLE FOR AN INJURY. RESULTING
FROM THEIR DISCRETIONARY THE
CITIZENS VESTED IN THEM. HOWEVER
THIS DOES NOT APPLY TO THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION. MORE LIKELY THAN
OTHER PUBLIC EMPLOYEES TO
COUNTER THIS PROBLEM THIS BILL
WILL SIMPLY MAKE CLEAR. THAT
DISCRETIONARY DECISIONS MADE BY
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITHIN THE
MINUTE IS PROVIDE IT WITH AN
EXISTING LAW. WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ATHLETIC
COMMISSION MR PETER VIEGAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND RESPECT US
FOR DRIVER. MR VEGAS MAKE MORE
MINUTES THANK YOU- SOME MEMBER
FONG AND MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AB THIRTEEN-
CLARIFIES. EXISTING LAW THAT THE
BALLOT APPROVALS AND ASSIGNMENTS
MADE BY THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN
THE COURSE OF CARRYING OUT HIS
DUTIES. SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO
CONSTANT CRITICISM AND POTENTIAL
LITIGATION THREATS. THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER CONSIDERS
NUMEROUS FACTORS. WHEN APPROVING
BALLOTS ARE MAKING ASSIGNMENTS.
THE FOREMOST BEING THE SAFETY.
OF THE ATHLETES. THAT THE
COMMISSION LICENSES AND
REGULATES THE EXTENT OF
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH AND
CONSIDERATION OF FACTORS IN
SELECTING OFFICIALS ARE PROVING
BALLOTS IS A DISCRETIONARY ACT
IN THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW THE EXECUTIVE BACK
OFFICERS THE HIGHEST. RANKING
STATE EMPLOYEE AND- OF THE
COMMISSION AND HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY. OF APPROVING
BALLOTS FOR BOXING KICKBOXING
MOUTAI IN MIXED MARTIAL ARTS AS
WELL AS ASSIGNING REFEREES AND
OFFICIALS TO THOSE SPORTS THE
BILL WILL FURTHER CLARIFIED THAT
THIS RESPONSIBILITY LOOK AT
ROCKY SPOTS ABILITY AND DUTY. IS
DISCRETIONARY THE BILL WILL SAVE
THE COMMISSION HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
POTENTIAL LITIGATION COSTS THE
COMMISSION HAS BEEN FORCED TO
DEFEND ISSUE STEMMING FROM THIS
LACK OF CLARITY. OF THE
DISCRETIONARY IMMUNITY ACT
MOBILE MULTIPLE TIMES. THE COST
TO THE COMMISSION'S BUDGET TO
PAY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
FOR DEFENSE VIS TAKES RESOURCES
AWAY FROM THE COMMISSION'S
PRIMARY GOAL WHICH IS THE HEALTH
SAFETY FAIRNESS INCONSISTENT
REGULATION OF THE EVENTS WE
OVERSEE AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT A. B.
THIRD EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN IS
PASSED. BY THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU THANK YOU WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES REGISTER IN OPPOSITION
SO MOVED ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM YOU MAY COME UP
THE MICROPHONE. SEEING NONE
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTEEN. PLEASE WHEN ASSIST
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. AND TO THE CHAIR WE HAVE
NO COMMENTS FROM THE PHONE OKAY.
ON OUR RETURN THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY THE THERE IS. A
SECOND BY FRIEDMAN- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOUNDED WHICH TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT- SO I TEACH
SORRY THANK YOU. SORRY SHOULD
WAIVE MORE WILDLY WELL- IN- YOUR
REMARKS YOU SAID YOU DIDN'T TO
THINK THAT COMMISSIONERS SHOULD
BE SUBJECT TO CONSTANT
CRITICISM- WHICH HAD A WHITE IT
SHOULD BE ANY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT WE'RE SUBJECT TO- CRITICISM
IS ONE THING BUT FOR THE OTHER
REASONS- THAT YOU STATED I THINK
THIS IS A- A VALID BILL INTO.
THE SPORTING. THANK THANK YOU
MISTER PRIME. THAT'S AFFIRMATIVE
THE CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH
BETTER CHAIR COMMIT MEMBERS SO
CLEAR FOR AND I. THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'LL THIS UP IT AT THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE FEES BE PAID TO
THE COMMISSION BY THE
CONTESTANTS TO BE DIRECTED
TOWARDS THE PURPOSE OF THE
COMMISSION- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. THE MOTION AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BOERNER HORVATH
BOERNER HORVATH I BALLADARES.
GALLAGHER AS I BLOOM. BLOOM I
CHOI HI. CHOI I MIKE FONG HI.
MIKE FONG HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN
I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE. OKAY
MEMBERS OF THAT ON A VOTE SEVEN
TO ZERO AB EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN HAS
PASSED AND LEAVE AND NO WE WON'T
LEAVE IT OPEN BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S HERE- SO WITH THAT-
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU- THE MEMBERS THAT CONCLUDES
THE BILL PRESENTATIONS FOR THE
DAY- WE HAVE ONE ITEM SONG
CALLED US THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FOR ACR ONE SEVENTY FOUR.
NAZARIAN HI THE SYRIAN I. OKAY
WELL. I HAVE A YOU CAN GIVE THE
LAST FEW YOUR AVAILABLE ONE OF.
THANK OKAY LET ME SEE I HAVE TO
GO THAT WAS MY CLOSING- RIGHT.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS THE OF THIS
THE ARTS CA TODAY WE ARE. WELL
THAT. I LIKE. INTERVENTION THERE
GOVERNMENT HOWEVER HERE ON TIME. RIGHT. THE THIS. SURE ENOUGH.
HAD. THANKS TRANSACTION
PRIMARIES. THAT REALLY SO THIS.
SEVEN WELL. FIFTEEN YOU CAN IT
WHEN YOU DO NORMAL SAN SEVEN
THREE ONE WITH AND THEN WE'LL
JUST IT OUT AB ONE. YEAH THAT
WILL WORK ON. OF THE REST. OF
COURSE OUT. THANK YOU YOU HEAR
ME BETTER THIS TIME. I CAN HEAR
SAY IS THAT SHE COULDN'T HEAR
THE LAST FEW. OKAY SPEAK UP
THANK YOU FOR GIVING. I THINK.
OKAY JUST A STROLL THE PHONES
ARE OFF. HE'S MUCH FOR. THE
PROGRAM. OKAY. THANK GOODNESS.
SINCE HER FIRST. THESE YES HELLO
ME GET- YEAH YEAH I DO WISH WE
HAD MORE HEARINGS JUST LIKE A
PRACTICE BUT. ALL GOOD. EIGHT
INTEGER.
IT WAS PRETTY QUICK YEP SHE
WANTED TO BE IN AND OUT WE GO NO
COULD. THROUGH YOU WILL GET A
FOR ME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP
DESK OR FROM. ALL RIGHTS ARE.
IT'S QUITE THE. BUT THEN LET'S
SAY YEAH THIS TURNED ON I THINK
I CAN BECAUSE THAT PRIORITIES
OFTEN. SO WHERE DO YOU LIVE IN A
WHICH WITH THAT THAT'S WHY OUT
THERE YEAH GEN I HAVE SEEN IT
THAT'S ALWAYS FULL PACKAGE NOT
ACTIVATE NOW SEEMS LIKE. YEAH
WILL PAY FOR THEIR TO GET IT
CHECKED RIGHT ONE MINUTE AT THE
AND LEAVE.